si on dira bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france vous vous
trouvez à new york
ça fait maintenant trente ans que vous
habitez cette ville
cette saisine du conseil d'état c'est
une sorte de cri de désespoir que
lancent les expatriés alors je crois que
je réponds en tant que psychologue
vous savez on a il ya toujours à partir
de moments par lh2 d'individus il ya
toujours des réactions très variées
donc je crois qu'il ya un certain nombre
de personnes qui sont effectivement
anxieuse après avoir entendu cette
nouvelle
tous les personnes qui ont de la famille
en france est il des problèmes et de la
famille qui ont des problèmes médicaux
surtout sinon un
vous allez oust et toujours avoir d un
certain nombre de personnes qui vont
être angoissé qui vont qui ont déjà des
des histoires de cet ordre là des
personnes qui sont déprimés comme je
crois que ça ça exacerbe les les
symptômes tout simplement où les
personnalités les aspects de
personnalités qui sont déjà présentes
justement quelle charge mentale pauvres
pour ces français qui ne savent pas
quand est-ce qu'ils pourront alors voir
leur famille en france
je crois que je crois qu'effectivement
certains s'en sont certains sons sont
anxieux d'autres sont confiants aussi
que s'il ya une situation très grave
qu'est ce qui se passe chez eux dans au
sein de leur famille je pense qu'ils
sont confiants que ils pourront
effectivement se rendre en france
mais je crois que oui il est de toute
façon c'est une période difficile pour
tout le monde donc ça rend
saran le degré d'anxiété et et surtout
de will look s'était lié à l'inconnu
aussi on est déjà depuis un an
très isolés les uns des autres et est
donc il ya une peur que que ça ne fasse
que durée ou s'amplifier donc donc c'est
ça surtout je crois que je crois que
tout le monde est inquiet tout le monde
tout le monde se demande quand va être
est ce qu'on va aboutir à quelque chose
quand va être la fin ceci dit les des
personnes que je vois pour l'instant on
sait une rune une nouvelle relativement
récente donc je n'ai pas vu de réactions
extrêmes intense à nouveau je crois que
depuis un an les gens ce sont du moins
parmi la population la plus jeune se
sont adaptés à utilise les moyens à leur
disposition de rentrer en contact avec
avec leurs familles et avec leurs amis
pour maintenir le contact et ça je crois
que c'est important que ce soit par par
téléphone ou par par vidéo avec zoom
festal mme et cetera skype tout le monde
mais je crois que c'est une c'est une
chose qui est particulièrement
importante en ce moment je crois que ça
ça aura ça rassurera tout le monde et
c'est pas la même chose qu'un contact
physique mais mais c'est quand même ce
sont des moyens que nous avons à l'heure
actuelle et dames
dernière question et c'est un tirage
vont en profiter puisque vous êtes aux
états unis qu'elle est actuellement la
situation face aux locaux vides 19
à la situation et que tout le monde
attend il ya eu une période de
vaccination
il n'y a pas très longtemps et là je new
york attend la livraison d'autres
vaccins je crois que non ce que je
connais de ça c'est que on est on est
dans une dans une période d'attenté
quelques en sera le le prochain livre
met entre parenthèses donc je crois que
c'est ça pour l'instant est évidemment
il ya il y à un degré d'anxiété chez
chez tout le monde par rapport à ça il
ya des gens qui attendent et qui sont
impatients d'avoir le vaccin je crois
que c'est la majorité est bien certain
keane et ne veulent pas merci beaucoup
en tout cas christine girard d'être
intervenu ce matin avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes psychologue et
psychanalyste à new york